[Applause]
we're back baby oh yeah
hello
it is fantastic to see you all um and
yes welcome welcome to ndc welcome to
oslo uh welcome to computational
creativity my name is uh dylan beatty
and this is what i look like when i'm
stuck in my house wearing a headset for
18 months uh i am the director and
founder and chief everything officer at
ursatoil which is a training and
strategy consultancy company that i
started at the start of last year so i
could do lots of travel that was the
worst idea anyone ever had
uh i'm a microsoft mvp with the
developer technologies program i run a
london.net user group and uh i do dumb
things with computers just to see if it
will work because i walked in someone
said are you the guy who write the song
about the bad apis yeah i write songs
about bad apis and uh i write songs
about code and sometimes i write code
about songs and i spent a whole bunch of
my life going i don't know if i want to
be a programmer or a musician eventually
i thought we should just mash these two
things together and invent a programming
language where you can do both at the
same time
uh which is not what i'm going to talk
to you about today you'll hear some bits
and pieces about that over the next
couple of days but if any of you does uh
want to go on linkedin and apply for all
of those sweet rock star developer jobs
go to codewithrockstar.com
and you can write programs in the
rockstar programming language which i
invented in a bar as a joke and now it's
a joke with a formal reference
implementation and a test suite and i am
the project manager of the joke which is
a weird thing to do with your weekends
now
uh
the last 18 months you've all been bored
off your ass and do you know how i know
that i did a talk at nbc london in
january 2020 all about rockstar and
esoteric languages and that kind of
stuff and they put it up on youtube as
they always do and that talk has had
something like 3 million views
which is you know
now that's you know if i ever need to
impress a teenager i think that might be
useful i'm not really sure what you do
with three million youtube views um
but uh so yeah a lot of people have
watched that video and a lot of people
got in touch and said is there any more
and i'm like oh there's so much like you
know you take all the good ideas you've
ever had and you have to cut out
everything which won't fit into a
one-hour talk and you get so much
interesting stuff and ideas and
perspectives that get kind of you know
left on the on the cutting room floor
and uh so what this talk is about
computational creativity is a sort of
it's some of those ideas that didn't
quite fit what i wanted to do with art
of code and it's just an exploration of
some of the things that we humans can do
in all kinds of you know creative
endeavors movies music film writing
problem solving using these wonderful
digital computer tools that are
ubiquitous now and uh
i was reading this book a little while
ago um anyone knows sid meier anyone
play any of his railroad yeah um so this
is his uh
sort of biography and it's very cool and
very nerdy and he talks about him and
all the people he's worked with the
games they've worked on and uh i had
already come up with the title for this
talk and then as i was reading this book
i found
this little snippet in there and uh it
talks about computational creativity
uses exactly that same phrase and he's
talking about they wanted to write a
mystery game where every time you played
the game it gave you an original like a
fresh mystery to solve and he has this
wonderful tone of phrase in here he says
uh
it was only a little bit impossible
which is not the same as completely
impossible and uh you know i i love that
idea of looking at the boundaries you
know what do we think is is impossible
to do what do you just go
but you know there's things which we are
it would take a sort of paradigm shift
in our understanding of the universe if
we were able to do that and there's
other stuff which is like well it's
impossible but if we got a slightly
faster machine and a better camera and
we cheated a little bit with some of
this maybe we could do that and so those
are some of the ideas that we're we're
going to be exploring today
and we're going to start here we are
going to start about 40 000 years ago uh
this is a cave painting that was uh
discovered in indonesia in 2019
and what i find amazing about this one
it is believed to be the earliest
example ever of human beings creating
art certainly the earliest example that
has survived so this is kind of you know
very shortly after
the first human being kind of you know
got some mud and went oh i can make a
mark on a wall they're like i can draw
stuff and i can depict the world around
me
and by the time they got to the end of
this art they're like i can make things
up
because if you look very closely this is
a scene of a hunt but one of the hunters
is a human being with a tail and another
one is a human being with a head like a
bird and so
this idea you know as soon as human
beings learn how to create things we
started to use them to make things up
and tell stories and use you know
fiction and creativity as a mechanism to
explore the world around us now art has
a heritage going back well you know 40
000 years we've come from this through
the invention of you know painting uh
sculpture sketching we've got artists
michelangelo and da vinci frida kahlo
hakusai all these kinds of things and in
the uh the mid 18th century
so we're talking about uh no the mid
19th century the 1840s i hate the way
historians do that because the first
century is the one that starts at zero
not at one thousand right so yeah uh
19th century 1840s there was a group of
artists in france um called the realists
now most painting up to that point was
uh very glamorous paintings of rich
people or it was paintings of god and
jesus and saints because those were kind
of the people who could afford art and
the realists were like we are bored of
that we want to paint reality as
accurately as we can we are not
interested in you know gold leaf and
stylized things we want to paint you
know pictures that show people what real
life actually looked like the realism
movement survived for you know decades
it proved quite influential and then in
the second half of the 19th century a
technological innovation came along that
basically wiped out the realists and
changed the world forever it was the
invention of photography
now
why would you labor over painting an
incredibly accurate picture of some poor
people digging up a field when you can
just go and take a photo of it
photography gave us a way of capturing
the world around us that you know it
wiped out one art form it eliminated
realism as a painting uh style you know
as a school of painting but it allowed
us to start capturing images like these
ones pivotal moments in history this
famous you know the milk drop experiment
of showing really really fast shutter
speeds giving us this insight into a
world we've never seen because we just
can't look fast enough until we use
technology to help us and so next time
you and your friends are out and you're
in a bar and you are taking selfies
now this photograph i found this by
typing drunkest picture ever taken into
reddit
and you know you can't imagine the
realist sitting down and painting this
but next time you snap a picture like
this just take a moment and remember the
realists who tried to do this using pens
uh paint brushes and oils and all those
kinds of things now
photography was just one example of a
you know a load of different
technologies that emerged over the
course of what we call the industrial
revolution kind of 1760 until the middle
of the 19th century um textiles was
mechanized agriculture mining
manufacturing transportation hundreds
and thousands of
human endeavors things people used to do
because there was no other way to do
them suddenly those things were getting
automated and the effects of that you
know the impact of those changes on our
society is still visible today all
around us now you have probably heard
the word luddite at some point in your
career you know the luddites are well
last year the luddites are the people
who still can't figure out zoom and they
don't i want everyone back in the office
and it's like come on just
work a camera you know it's not that
hard um but luddite has been the sort of
slightly derogatory term for people who
oh i don't really do email i don't like
computers i'm not sure about cars i want
to go to work on a horse you know that
kind of thing and the luddites are named
after a person
they're named after this guy in this
picture this is ned lud and uh ned lud
represented a bunch of weavers who
thought that looms automated textile
looms were a threat to their livelihood
and so they went around smashing them up
with hammers and so what this depicts
you know new technology comes along and
there are always going to be people who
embrace the possibility they just see
this as wow there's all this new stuff
we can do and there are the people who
go oh i don't like that it's going to
take our jobs i don't like change i
don't like it when you know we have
progress going on in society that's not
really my thing and they will resist
that and they will oppose that now
the people in this picture
are computers
until about 1950 the word computer had
existed we had computers in english it
was a job computers were people who uh
this is nasa all of these people worked
at nasa in the 1950s and 1960s so the
time of you know the first american
space launches uh the apollo missions
the origins of things like the space
shuttle program and these were people
who did calculations that's what a
computer was it's a person who did sums
for a living now you've probably seen
there's a a movie came out a couple
years ago called hidden figures which
was uh based on a true story about a
group of uh african-american women who
were working at nasa during the 1950s
and you probably remember this scene
what it does
now calculation
is uh
most calculations the kind of
calculations that they're doing at nasa
that was not uh you know a terribly
creative form of mathematics they were
crunching numbers to work out what their
spacecraft needed to do how long do we
burn the engines how heavy can this
component afford to be and you know
those kinds of calculations were
obviously ripe for automation because it
took a long time to do them now the um
the woman talking on the blackboard
there in that clip uh octavia spencer is
the actress playing her the character is
called dorothy vaughan and she's a real
person she worked at nasa from the 1950s
until 1971. so while she was working at
nasa human beings walked on the moon we
invented the hewlett packard 35 pocket
scientific calculator we invented the
intel 4004 microprocessor the xerox
laser printers arpanet email and by the
time she left computer was not a person
anymore computer was a machine it was a
calculating device now you know those uh
innovations like i said calculation
wasn't really yeah these people were
like this could take our job so like we
have more interesting stuff we could do
with our mathematical skills and when
you solve two plus two equals four there
isn't really much of a question about
who takes the credit for that result
especially if you're doing the math to
try and beat the soviet union to be the
first people on the moon and and win the
space race now when i was a kid uh we
were not allowed to use calculators in
school we were taught how to use them
but the teachers were like when you grow
up you are not going to have a
calculator in your pocket hands up if
you've got a calculator in your pocket
yeah i'm sorry mrs marshall i think
we've won that one um but you know you
had to learn your times tables and that
kind of stuff but i was kind of because
i was a nerdy kid i was one of the early
adopters i was one of the only kids in
my school who did their homework on a
word processor everyone else did it by
hand and i had these long arguments with
teachers about whether i was allowed to
use a spell checker
because on the one hand the teachers are
like no no you need to learn how to
spell all the words and i said well what
if i don't know how to spell the word
and they said we'll look it up in a
dictionary and i was like but if i don't
know how to spell it how am i supposed
to find it do i just start the beginning
and dig and also the dictionary tells
you what words mean you know why would i
be using a word in an essay that i don't
know what it means and we engineered
this very very weird compromise i was
allowed to use the word perfect spell
checker
for uh geography and history but i
wasn't allowed to use it for english
i was not allowed to use a spell checker
for english because my english teacher
was like well no i'm teaching you
english so that would be cheating but
you can use it in all your other classes
and i don't care and you know we ended
up with this sort of like i said weird
compromise but all a spell checker can
really do is it can look at the words
that you've given it and it can say do
those words appear in this list
using some form of case insensitive
accent insensitive collation i would
assume there if you want to know what
that is come to my talk tomorrow you can
learn all about that now
problem with spell checkers they don't
know what the words mean they don't
actually solve any problems they just
tell you does that pattern of characters
appear and uh this this problem has been
immortalized in this wonderful poem by
gerald zar owed to a spell checker
i have a spelling checker it came with
my pc it plainly marks for my review
mistakes i cannot see i strike a key and
type a word and wait for it to say
whether i am wrong or right it shows me
straight away
now
when i wasn't arguing the merits of
spell checkers in mrs jones english
class i was doing what teenage kids did
in the 1990s i was riding bikes and i
was playing guitar and going to the
movies and in 1991 the movie everybody
was talking about was terminator 2
judgment day because it was brilliant it
had a killer robot from the future and
then it had a killer robot from the
future it turned out to be one of the
good guys and it had arnie and it had
motorcycles and it had guns and roses on
the soundtrack and it had this thing
this
was something none of us had ever seen
on a cinema screen before the t-1000
liquid metal hunter killer terminator
robot now
the special effects which allowed them
to realize scenes like this one here
from terminator 2 they had a budget of 5
million 36 people worked for a year on
just the t1000 just that liquid metal
effect it was absolutely pioneering it
won the academy award for best visual
effects and you know uh plaudits from
throughout the industry and stuff but it
was not the first time somebody had used
a computer to make a movie in 1982
a unknown director guy called steven
lisberger created a movie called tron
now tron was massively controversial
because they used computers to make the
film now tron was produced by disney it
was distributed by disney it was paid
for by disney it was not made by disney
because disney's animators refused to
work on it they boycotted the project
and said we are not going to animate a
project that uses computers because we
think they are a threat to our industry
and our livelihood so all the animation
that the hand animation in tron was
actually done in japan now
you know tron mixed it was fascinating
what they did with it it had a mixture
of live action footage hand animated
animation and about 20 minutes of
completely computer generated animated
scenes
this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and of course the first law of hollywood
is if there's an explosion you have to
have a tire bouncing out of it that's
just the rules
now
if you watch that clip closely they did
not have the technology to mix
live-action and computer animation so
whenever you see a human actors face all
of the kind of computer graphics and
that have been drawn by hand on top of
the film cells but the scenes with no
humans in them those were animated
entirely on a computer now tron was one
of the most innovative and visually
stunning movies ever made it was not
nominated for an academy award let alone
winning it um it was disqualified
because the academy of motion picture
arts and scientists said that using
computers to make movies was cheating
now the weird thing was there was
already a precedent they were quite
happy if you had a computer in your
movie with computer graphics in the
movie appearing on the computer screen
that was in the movie so films like
alien where they have computers then
they'll that's fine you know you're
allowed to do that but the thing was
doing computer graphics was actually
incredibly expensive take a look at this
scene uh this is the glider approach
sequence from john carpenter's escape
from new york
so we've got kurt russell is a snake
pliskin who's being sent to new york to
rescue the president who's been
kidnapped i don't actually remember the
plot of that movie very much but if you
watch this scene closely you see that
there the green screen wireframe view of
him coasting in over manhattan they
couldn't afford to do that on a computer
because they just had a hollywood motion
picture budget you couldn't get enough
computer time that scene was shot in a
sound stage so they got a big room kind
of like this one big dark room they
covered the floor in black felt and they
got a load of cardboard boxes they
painted them black and they ran green
neon piping around the edges they put an
ultraviolet light up so all the green
glowed and then they just walked a
camera through like this and that's how
they got this gliding effect and the
person who created that effect was james
cameron who went on to do terminator and
titanic and avatar and all those kinds
of movies now
most of the time in hollywood if you
wanted to do computer graphics you faked
it because it was easier to hire people
to draw the computer graphics how they
made max headroom it's how they did all
the computer graphics in the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy tv
series but tron was like we are actually
going to make it using a computer and
they did it on this thing here this is
the phonely f1 it was a one-of-a-kind
overclocked pdp-10 it took six hours to
render a single frame of footage it like
i said couldn't combine live action so
anything where you had a human being
they kind of give the computer graphic
to the animators and say we need you to
paint this onto here um and they did it
now like i said tron was disqualified
eventually 20 years later the academy
one we might have made a mistake here
and uh they awarded toronto lifetime
achievement for innovation in uh
cinematography and computer graphics but
by the time terminator 2 came along the
balance had flipped you know computers
were widespread and movie and cinema
television production and uh they made
kind of they made hard things easy and
they made some impossible things not
quite so impossible anymore and they
started raising some really interesting
questions
about who actually created the scenes
that audiences were seeing on their
cinema screens
now in scenes like this one from peter
jackson's lord of the rings trilogy um
all of those orcs on that battlefield
there they are not just kind of computer
generated characters all of their
behavior is being generated the computer
is doing the acting and the computer is
doing the costumes and the computer is
doing the choreography it's a system
they created called massive the multiple
agent simulation system in a virtual
environment and all of those have got
just like you know bots in quake death
matches and stuff they've got some
relatively simple behavior that just is
very very well rendered and uh there's a
lovely story if you've seen the third
lord of the rings movie with the the
giant war elephants that come on the
first time they ran that scene a bunch
of the soldiers turned around and liked
it because their programming said get
off this battlefield you are in danger
and they came out a bit later and
they're like actually that was just a
bug they were programmed to find an
empty area if they couldn't get to where
the action was uh but by that point the
story was out and so it's a good
opportunity to retell it but you know
we can we're getting to a point now
where you can render just about anything
if a filmmaker can imagine that
computers can realize that and they can
get it on a screen and you can look at
it and a couple years ago
we met this guy
now who is that
well there is an argument that says that
is muftakin he's a fictional character
owned by lucasfilm limited he's
copyrighted and they are free to do
whatever they like and there is another
school of thought which says no no that
is clearly a digital reproduction of a
dead british actor called peter cushing
and
we are starting to see actual lawsuits
about these kinds of things now in this
particular instance it was all done uh
there's a little snippet i want to show
you this is from an abc nightline
feature about how they did that how they
created that peter cushing effect
therefore
um
the most subtle details you can imagine
the makers
now if you think we can go too far yes
we can look at this this should never
have happened this was an abomination
against uh human decency you know but
this is the point there are no
constraints now on what filmmakers can
do if they have an idea um there was i
read a review of uh the recent star wars
trilogy which said you know we've got
living actors playing dead characters
we've got dead actors playing living
characters it's at a point now where
even death is not a barrier to becoming
a hollywood star
but
we're getting to a point now i was at a
devoxx in the uk a couple of weeks ago
and there was a team there showing off
real-time deep faking for video calls
which is some really kind of sinister
and quite scary technology because
that's at the moment it is impossible to
do that convincingly but it is only a
little bit impossible it is not
completely impossible and we are going
to start seeing all kinds of stuff
coming out with uh you know deep fakes
and digital avatars and all these kinds
of things and uh it raises some very
very important questions that we need to
start thinking about
we're entering an
anything at any era in time
even if they would never say those
things
so
for instance they could have me say
things like
i don't know
kettlemonger was right
now you see i will never say these
things
at least
but
someone else would
someone
like jordan
this is a dangerous time
moving forward we need to be more
vigilant with what we trust from the
internet
now that there is the perfect storm
threat model because deep faking speech
is difficult because speech people talk
at different speeds they talk faster
they talk slower so if you have a voice
impersonation you can tweak the stuff
with a with technology a little bit but
uh you know you imagine uh somebody like
you got a
matthew mcconaughey who has this kind of
very laid-back text and draw accent and
you want to deep fake him to sound like
joe pasquale he talks really fast you
can't do it because you can't do it fast
enough because you don't know what
matthew mcconaughey has said yet because
he hasn't got there so you can't
translate it and put in the right point
but if you have people who can do vocal
impressions and you run that through
motion capture you get this kind of deep
fake video technology you can produce
even real-time video clips which will
probably fool most people as to who it
is they're watching and what that person
is actually saying now
one of the big questions that is being
raised online is you know who's
responsible who's liable for this kind
of stuff if uh
in the age of print media if somebody
printed a story that wasn't true i could
sue them and this was well established
because they're a publisher who has made
a decision somebody who is an individual
who is liable under the legal system and
can be called up to appear in court has
said yes we will run that story we'll
sell a bunch of newspapers and it'll
probably make us more money than we'll
lose in the ensuing lawsuits and fines
and stuff and for a long time there was
this open question about how is this
going to work on the internet in the
1990s it looked for a little while like
websites and internet providers could be
held liable for anything that was
transmitted
across them so uh let's say you go on uh
facebook and uh mark has put a comment
on facebook um where he says something
about me that i don't like so i'm like
all right i'm gonna sue mark zuckerberg
because facebook made that possible and
we honestly didn't know you know there
was this open question is a website a
newspaper or is a website something more
akin to a telephone line because those
were the legal precedents we were
working with now
section 230 of the uh communication
telecommunications act in the united
states
is this no provider or user of an
interactive computer service shall be
treated as the publisher or speaker of
any information provided by another
information content provider so what
that means is if i put something on your
website and someone else doesn't like it
they can sue me but they can't sue you
websites are like the postal service
they are considered neutral and the
content that's on there is uh that
considered to be you know transparent
what they call common carriers in in
some places but you know we're entering
this kind of murky area now where it
used to be just most websites were just
a big bag of information and they'd show
you whatever it was that you could find
but now we are getting curating
algorithms we are getting things like
social media feeds which are deciding
what they're going to show you and
that's not a human editor making an
editorial decision about what content to
run that is an algorithm that is going
in and saying oh we think you'll click
on this we think that person is going
gonna click on this and uh for a while
there if you went onto twitter it would
show you top tweets first and every
couple of days you can switch it off
because you don't want top tweets first
and every couple of days it would switch
it back on it's like oh no we think you
really do want top tweets that's what
you want and uh
you know this is algorithmic it's
optimizing for advertisers and
advertising revenue based on user
engagement and it isn't like you can go
to the editor of twitter and call them
and say we're gonna sue you because of
what your your algorithm does now uh how
many of you watch youtube and you know
when you get to the end of a youtube
video there's a recommendation
have you ever seen a recommendation that
said that's enough youtube for today
like youtube's algorithm the ideal like
the perfect perfect score for that
algorithm is somebody who one day they
get a laptop they open up they go on
youtube and they never go outside again
that is the behavior it is optimizing
towards because all it's doing is saying
watch another video watch another video
watch another video which it doesn't
have anything else to recommend or it's
got his videos and the more you watch
the more i don't know algorithmic doggy
treats or whatever they use to train
these things that it gets now i'm not
saying this is complete doom and gloom i
do actually love recommendations because
i use spotify a lot and spotify keeps
popping up these little daily mixers
which are mixtures of songs i love songs
i forgot i loved because i've not
listened to them in like 20 years and
new music and new releases from bands
that i didn't know about all that kind
of stuff and uh one of those youtube
recommendations that popped up for me
last year
was a guy in switzerland who just
restores machine tools in silence and
it's brilliant there's no music there's
no dialogue it's just him in his
workshop you never see his face and it's
like these 20-minute very zen videos of
him fixing up old tools and planes and
vices and stuff and i'd never have found
that if it wasn't for the the
recommendation algorithm but
you know we have these increasingly
powerful and sophisticated algorithms
that are being deployed in all kinds of
scenarios and they raise questions about
you know who's responsible for the
behavior of those algorithms who gets
the credit if they do something good
who's liable if they do something bad
but it also raises the question of can
we trust the platforms that the
algorithms are being deployed onto
anyone ever heard of knight capital
in 2012 knight capital was the single
biggest equities trader on the new york
stock exchange uh in uh first quarter of
that year they did nearly 300 million
dollars of uh equities trading 17 of all
the trades on the nasdaq stock index
went through knight capital system and
they had a piece of software called
smars smars which was automated software
for doing very very rapid stock exchange
trading now in 2012 there was a bunch of
laws brought out something called the
retail liquidity program which
effectively relaxed some of the
regulations around being able to connect
automated systems directly into the
financial trading backbone that runs the
stock markets and uh knight capital they
took their smart software and they got a
team to do a bunch of work to upgrade it
to incorporate all the new rules and on
august the first
they ran out the upgrade they deployed
this upgrade onto eight servers the
eight servers in there their trading
cluster
except they actually only deployed it
onto seven now buried somewhere inside
the code of smars there was a thing
called power peg and power peg's job was
if you said i want to buy a thousand
shares of that company there
nobody would be selling a thousand
shares so powerpeg would go we'll get
200 from them 50 from them 150 from
those people and it would put in these
trades until it reached the limit and
then it would switch the thing off now
powerpeg had been uh removed it hadn't
been used in nine years but it hadn't
been removed it was still there it was
disabled it was disabled by a feature
flag and all the people who were working
at the company in 2012
didn't know what that feature flag was
for because none of them had been there
when it was used
and this was the flag that they used to
turn on the new stock exchange rules the
retail liquidity thing so they deploy
the new code onto seven servers and then
they flip the config on eight of them
and one of them wakes up this dormant
code from nine years ago whose job is to
buy and sell things on the stock
exchange
now it had a safety check that had been
commented out it had been removed from
the code
because well no one's using it you know
it's going to be removed any day now it
hasn't been used for years and years and
years they had created an infinite loop
plugged into the new york stock exchange
that spends real money the first thing
they did was they went oh crap this is
really bad and they rolled the old
software back onto the other seven
servers but they didn't reset the flag
so now you have eight infinite loops
plugged into the new york stock exchange
spending real money it took them about
45 minutes to figure out what was
happening and shut the thing down and uh
the security and equities commission
report these are normally very very dry
but this one is actually funny because
it summarizes it as a night capital had
accumulated an unintended multi-billion
dollar portfolio of securities in
approximately 45 minutes
um they did they ultimately lost nearly
half a billion dollars on the back of
that computer mistake um and they had to
pay a 12 million dollar fine because
obviously that's really gonna sting when
you've just lost half a billion because
not only is what they did incredibly
stupid and negligent it's also a
criminal offence to uh deploy the wrong
software and you know mess up the stock
market the way that they did but you
know
who's to blame
there's an engineer whose job was to
roll out that code onto eight servers
and they only rolled it out into seven
does that sound like a half billion
dollar mistake
you know i've made mistakes like that
unfortunately no one's ever come after
me for half a billion dollars um the
developers who reuse the feature flag
you ever reuse the flag in software
because the process to get a new one is
going to take three months and you have
to have this thing live now because of
the new financial regulations that
sounds like a situation a lot of us has
been in um you know maybe somewhere in a
meeting someone was like we really
shouldn't do this and the boss went no
it's all right it's on me you just go
ahead with it i'll get it sorted out and
of course they never did never happened
you know who's to blame that who accepts
the the liability now as developers
we're used to shipping software that
eventually goes on and sometimes makes
somebody else an awful lot of money and
uh we don't necessarily go well actually
you give me all of the money because
that's my code that made all the money
for you and the flip side of that is
when our code makes a mistake that loses
someone a lot of money we're not
normally personally liable for that kind
of thing now
this wiped out knight capital that's the
graph of their stock exchange price they
crashed the competitor came along and
basically bought them for pennies and
that was it knight capital now exists in
history as a fun company to talk about
in talks about what happens when
algorithms go wrong and how to scare
stock brokers but
the thing about that scenario is that
even though it was this incredibly high
speed automated trading solution
it was still possible to work out what
had happened you could draw a line
between okay this order came in and it
went to that trade and that got split
and that got split and you could sort of
do a forensic analysis and figure out
now this happened it's doing stuff human
beings do but it's doing it in
milliseconds instead of hours and that
was kind of the problem here but they
were fundamentally just automating a
process that was familiar to a majority
of the people who work in that industry
now
there are two things that are true right
across the technology sector one of them
is that recruitment is a massive pain in
the ass looking for a job sucks finding
developers sucks everything about
recruitment is horrible and the other
one is that if we see a problem in our
industry which is a massive pain in the
ass we try and automate a solution so we
don't have to do it anymore and uh about
a decade ago amazon tried this amazon
said out in 2014 they hired a team to
automate recruitment and the data set
they gave them they gave them every
single cv every single resume of
everyone who had applied for a job at
amazon within the last five years along
with the data on how far they got
through the interview process and
whether they subsequently got offered a
job and so they ran a whole bunch of
different neural networks and machine
learning models across this thing and
basically their brief was we hired these
people find the patterns so we know what
we are looking for
and uh it worked they found some
patterns they read something like 500
different models
they discovered that if you had been to
a women's college you probably did not
get a job with amazon they discovered
that if you had been to certain
community colleges you were getting
downgraded and were not getting a job
with amazon people from certain
geographic districts were getting ranked
down and were not getting jobs with
amazon and the people who did get jobs
with amazon was a total crapshoot they
had nothing in common whatsoever that
could be distilled from the information
in those cvs now the algorithms worked
what they did is they uncovered a
pattern which was you have some serious
systemic bias in the way that your
hiring practices work and basically you
reject the people you don't like based
on your cultural prejudices and then
randomly hire somebody from the pile
that's left now they uh amazon are
adamant that they never actually did
this they they never ordered they never
used it to hire people it was an
experiment uh it taught them some stuff
about themselves which i'm sure they
went away and did the responsible thing
with but
you know this is a big deal when you're
building uh any kind of machine learning
system you're reliant on data to train
that model and help get it right and
getting data that doesn't reflect
cultural biases it turns out to be very
very difficult now a little while ago
twitter had this wonderful feature that
if you uploaded a photograph that had
some people in it it would try and find
a person and it would kind of crop in on
their face when you were viewing it in
the twitter web feed and uh it turned
out that well
it kind of worked like it found people's
faces but it was overwhelmingly favoring
particular kinds of people's faces
it was favoring white guys all the time
anything the twitter algorithm believed
to be a white guy would be prioritized
regardless of the composition of the
image now i ran a whole bunch of
pictures through this to kind of get get
an idea for it uh so brad pitt and
jennifer aniston whichever way around
you put them brad always gets the
spotlight on that um if you upload
bender from futurama in the same picture
as uh jacinda arden the prime minister
of new zealand
twister's algorithm goes oh no bender's
got a faceier face than that other
person we're gonna crop and highlight on
that
now you know i don't think anybody sat
down on purpose and went let's write a
really sexist racist algorithm and put
it on twitter for all our users i think
what has happened here is a bunch of
engineers they got a data set now it's
an unfortunate fact that most of the
photographs in the public domain are of
white men because most of the famous
people in our society are white men
because we elect white politicians and
we go and see film starring white male
actors and we watch uh olympic games and
sporting events and so those kind of
celebrities tend towards a certain you
know ethnicity and gender bias but
there's eight billion people on this
planet and you know i know gender and
ethnicity are not absolute concepts but
i'm pretty sure if you said right
everyone who's like yeah i'm a white guy
you will come over here you'd end up
with about that many people relative to
the rest of the human beings on this
planet now what that means is that if
you build a facial recognition algorithm
which is 98 accurate on you the 10 other
white guys on your team the 5 000 white
guys in your photography data set and a
couple of your sample groups your
algorithm is only nine percent accurate
because you've only tested it on this
tiny little sliver of population
now
this is a problem you know and i don't
think it's a problem that necessarily
arises out of malice or intent i think
all of the people who build these
algorithms are genuinely trying to
solve a problem that they see and
they're trying to do it in a way that
works as effectively as possible but
they are being hamstrung by the fact
that there are these biases and the data
there are biases in the teams and
there's biases in the way that society
informs the work that they do so you
know we can fix it first of all we do
need better data if you're doing
anything with machine learning look at
where the data came from and you know
look at that data and say is there any
possibility that this has been biased in
favor of famous people wealthy people
rich people employed people college
graduates look for those kind of biases
in your data sets
better teams you know have somebody in
the room or on the slack with you who
you show that and they go hey you know
what i just ran your algorithm on me and
it didn't work and they'd be like oh
that's interesting um you know let's dig
a little deeper into why maybe this
thing isn't working for everybody
and we can make a better world you know
i'm uh completely up for trying to do
that now we have accomplished some
absolutely astonishing things in uh you
look at the impact that technology has
had on uh us and the society that we
live in the world all around us the last
18 months
we've been doing conferences like this
and if you said to me two years ago
you're gonna do a conference but no
one's allowed to travel anywhere and
you're not even allowed to go outside
i've been like no we're not but we made
it happen we have the technology we have
bandwidth and we have cameras and one of
the things that i think is absolutely
wonderful about the world we live in is
that the cost of access to information
has just been coming down and down and
down and down if you need to uh repair a
tractor or you need to set a bone or you
need to identify a parasite that's been
eating your crops you can look that
stuff up online right now for free you
can get a 100 smartphone i can get a
secondhand smartphone or you can you
know go to a library and use a terminal
and all that kind of stuff is available
anywhere and people can get access to
answers to questions now when i was a
kid i grew up in southern africa i grew
up in zimbabwe and if i had a question
i could ask a grown-up or i could go and
look in the library i basically had
access you know my parents and the stuff
they knew and the books they had in the
house there was the library there were
my teachers now the kind of questions
that mattered to me as a kid were
questions like who would win in a fight
between optimus prime and darth vader
and uh the borrowdale school library was
woefully lacking on appropriate
reference material on this front but you
know i had a pretty privileged
upbringing i was like what is the
fastest anyone has ever ridden a bmx
what do you mean you don't know come on
that's gotta be in here somewhere but
there are kids out there all over the
world right now who have really
important questions about you know their
uh identity healthcare how they fit into
society and once upon a time they
probably have spent their whole lives
just miserable in some small town
somewhere going i don't belong and i
don't fit in and i'm really unhappy and
now they can go online and they can like
why am i different and i'll get people
all over the planet going hey you know
you're not different it's just there's
no one else is interesting you in the
town where you live it's fine there's
loads of us come out and meet us it's
going to be okay and i think that's
worth it i think that's absolutely worth
it and
if it means we got to go through 10 or
15 years of russian botnets and fake
news and twitter bias to maintain that
freedom of access to information for the
people are actually looking for it then
i'm up for the challenge let's
absolutely do that now
one of the most uh significant questions
about computation we've talked about uh
calculation we've talked about spell
checking we've talked about you know
visual rendering and deep fakes and all
these kinds of things we've talked about
machine learning and somewhere in there
there was always this big question you
know what kind of computers are we you
know what what kind of computational
model does the human brain actually use
and will we ever be able to create an
artificial one now uh there is a lovely
quote from edgar dixtra who says the
question of whether a computer can think
is no more interesting than the question
of whether a submarine can swim
but
maybe think is the wrong word you know
we're english we have this word think
and we talk about how we build a
thinking computer build a thinking
machine but think is just like whatever
you do with your brain it's this massive
umbrella term what do you think oh how's
the where's the library i think it's
down there two blocks on the left i
think uh i think jimi hendrix is
massively overrated i think i want a
sandwich i think i love you these are
not the same process you know all these
different uh problem solving and
emotional processes that we humans go to
we call them all thinking just because
we don't have any model for breaking it
down into something more nuanced but
maybe we can look at a specific kind of
computational process maybe we can look
at playing a game of chess for example
now
it turns out the oldest chess playing
computer program is older than computers
alan turing wrote a chess program in
pencil in a notebook in about 1948
before there were any computers in the
world capable of running it
and then he went through and he executed
it manually using a pen and paper to
keep track of all the registers and uh
wrote up some notes about this is
actually quite good and about three
decades later somebody implemented it
and they found a couple of bugs but it
worked it was a working chess playing
program written for a computer that
didn't exist yet by somebody who never
actually got to run it themselves now
the first computer chess championship
was held in 1974 and in 1974 most
computers you know a decent human player
could beat any chess computer out there
but computers got better and better and
better and better in 1990
when was it deep thought 1989
uh gary kasparov a russian world chess
champion or soviet at the time chess
champion
he played a machine called deep thought
which was an ibm supercomputer and it
matched the force of draw so we had the
best human chess player in the world
being forced into a draw he went on to
win in the next game but it kind of
rattled him and then about eight years
late 1997 ibm came back with a thing
called deep blue and it won it defeated
kasparov three games to two and for the
first time a computer had beaten the
world's best human chess player in
tournament play now from that point it's
game over for the humans basically
magnus carlsen who he's norwegian isn't
he carlson um and he says i don't bother
playing computers because it's no fun
you know i'm the best chess player in
the world and they just kick my ass
every time and it's not even interesting
but there was a little period a little
while there
where uh magnus carlsen uh became not
magnus carson kasparov gary kasperov
became interested in something called
some people call it hybrid chess some
people call it centaur chess some people
like cyborg chess and basically what it
is is each player is a human with a
computer and so you've got a human being
using a computer to go is this a good
move is that a bad move and then using
that to play and for a while there
before the super computers kind of you
know accelerated and took over we had
this weird situation where you know a
reasonably good we're not talking world
champion standard a reasonably good
human chess player with a laptop
could beat international grand masters
and the chess supercomputers because
something about that synergy of human
creativity and you know mechanical
calculated problem solving gave them a
competitive edge and the really
interesting thing about that if you read
the stuff that kasparov wrote while he
was working on this he believed that the
discriminating factor wasn't the quality
of the human player or the quality of
the computer it was the quality of the
interface between them how quickly could
that human being get their ideas into
the computer and how easily could they
understand the responses that were
coming back from it and you know
somebody who cares a lot about usability
and user experience i think that that's
absolutely fantastic you know this idea
that the uh kind of limiting factor is
not the humans or the machines it's how
good are we at turning machines into
tools that work harmoniously with what
our brains are trying to do as we try
and make sense of the world around us
and solve these kinds of problems and uh
that brings us to the home stretch
because the last thing i want to talk to
you about about today is exactly this
hybrid creativity humans and computers
working together to create things that
would not otherwise exist
now uh a couple of years ago
some of you may have seen this guy uh
michelle sack he gave a talk here at uh
nbc and i saw him give it a couple of
other conferences about writing heavy
metal riffs using machine learning and
net and i've just got a little excerpt
what he did is he downloaded uh all of
the guitar music for the first four
metallica albums anthrax slayer a whole
bunch of other bands like that and he
turned it into a format that uh ml.net
could understand and he ran this huge
training algorithm network across it and
then said to it i would like you to
write me a heavy metal song now please
and this is what happened
this
so there you go heavy metal riff written
by a uh neural network based on
metallica songs and uh created using
some code that mikhail put together now
at that point i saw that talk and i
thought it's brilliant we need to do
some stuff with this because that's how
my brain works and uh i started thinking
all right we've got uh machine learning
is capable of writing music that's kind
of okay we can do some stuff with that
what about lyrics and i started digging
around now the state of the art
with uh computer-generated text is gpt-3
have any of you got access to gpd3
uh no me neither i keep asking for it
and i think i shouldn't have told them
that i wanted to use it to write
metallica songs because i think maybe
they think i'm being frivolous with
their technology
but last year the guardian newspaper in
the uk it published an article written
entirely by the gpt3 uh
i don't even know what to call this
thing it's a neural network but it's
like a neural network on a scale we've
not really seen before um it's a natural
language parser and all they did is they
said to the system
please write a short op-ed 500 words
keep the language simple and concise and
focus on why humans have nothing to fear
from ai
and what they did is they ran that uh i
think they ran that eight times and then
one of the editors just went right that
paragraph that paragraph but that's how
editors put together newspaper stories
they'll take a whole bunch of stuff that
a
journalist has submitted they'll take
that copy and they'll kind of curate it
they'll pick the best bits and maybe
tweak a little bit so it flows better
and so effectively the journalist who
wrote this article it was edited by a
human but it was written by a machine
and run in a newspaper using exactly the
same process that you would use to uh
publish something written by a human
now like i said i can't get access to
gpt3 i'm not sure why i keep asking i
haven't heard anything back so we're
going to use a slightly more primitive
approach to generate some lyrics for the
purpose of our exercise we're going to
use something called a markov chain now
markov chains are they're a lot of fun
to play around with basically you take a
massive chunk of text and you analyze it
and you look for patterns of words and
then you run a randomizing algorithm
that puts together text that follows the
patterns that found in your original
training corpus but which is original
now uh we're going to do a little work
to example there let's say that we um
we train a markov chain on the lyrics to
hotel california by eagles and then
we're like right we want you to write us
a line of eagle's lyrics and so we say
okay we're going to start with the word
she now uh in hotel california she does
a lot of things she stood in the doorway
and she lit up a candle and she showed
me the way and she got the mercedes benz
and what the markov chain is going to do
is it's going to pick one of those four
words at random what did she do she
showed yeah there we go all right stick
showed in there and now we're like okay
go back to hotel california what words
could come after showed in that piece of
text in that bit of writing uh the only
one we've got in there is she showed me
the way so that's got gotta be me that's
the only thing that follows it now what
comes after me well she showed me the
way please bring me my wine so we've got
the we've got my 50 50 toss a coin she
showed me my and what are my things in
hotel california well i had the cool
wind in my hair my sight grew dim please
bring me my wine pick one of those at
random there we go she showed me my hair
which is nonsensical but it's
nonsensical in a kind of you know if don
henley sang that in 1970 you'd probably
just accept that he'd written it right
now there is a site out there called
lyrics.rip which has basically built
markov chains for every single band by
getting all of their lyrics and it will
just generate you honestly like go and
uh make me some metallica lyrics or some
ac dc lyrics and uh there's a guy on
youtube who has taken a bunch of these
uh funk turkey is the name of the
channel and he takes these markov chain
lyrics but then he writes all the music
himself to go with it and puts up these
videos and stuff and so what i wanted to
do is i wanted to take mikhail's
tensorflow and machine learning model
take the music from that mark off chain
some metallica lyrics now there's a
little bit of curation involved i kind
of i hit the refresh button about 20 or
30 times and i picked uh you know lines
and paragraphs that worked well together
and looked out for some patterns but
what i did
i took that
i took the thing i put them all together
and because i was on lockdown i sat
around for a bunch of time now i'm not
gonna play this one live you wanna see
live music come and see the party
tomorrow mainly because i don't really
want to bounce up and down on this stage
very much
but here you go take a listen to this
and tell me what you think
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
and so there you go friends the music of
the future
written by a website with uh music
generated on mikhail's laptop lovingly
curated by me and the lockdown all stars
there it's my green screen band
that bass player is a jerk he really is
um
thank you very much for coming along are
there any questions
you'll need to shout because i can't see
you all i can see is the lights
but if there's no questions it'll be
just like doing this on zoom where
there's never any questions
that's like any questions oh oh no you
went to get a biscuit all right
nevermind
cool
all right thank you very much for coming
along folks yeah
yes
have you heard any
may songs have been written by an
algorithm
so you know the whole turing test thing
about you know one day we will build a
machine that is so smart that you can no
longer distinguish it from a human being
um unfortunately my theory is that the
turing test is not going to get passed
by machines getting smarter it's going
to get passed by people getting dumber
and i have certainly heard music written
by people that they probably should have
written with an algorithm there's quite
a lot of that in the charts most days um
no i mean there's uh the stuff you've
got probably got an app on your phone if
any of you got an iphone uh there's a
thing on there now where you can just
sing into it and it'll generate backing
for you by doing like a harmonic
analysis of your voice and putting in
chords and drums and all that kind of
stuff and uh you know i've used uh
algorithmic drum loops and stuff in
music i've done i'm absolutely certain
if you put on the radio for half an hour
you're going to hear something in there
which maybe not an entire song generated
by an algorithm and uh you know probably
i think most lyrics are still being
written by people by hand um but you
know
music lyrics are nonsensical you stop
that sounds like nonsense but it's very
metallicary nonsense and if they put
that on an album you're probably just
gonna go all right wow this is so deep i
wonder what the hidden symbolism of all
these kinds of lyrics is um
but uh i'm sure you know it's
only a matter of time before we have a
completely you know digital simulated
celebrity who has simulated algorithmic
music at which one is like well uh
who owns it where did that come from is
the person who wrote the algorithm do
they get the royalties is it the person
who programmed the avatar is it the
person who owns the hardware that the
whole thing is running on
because you know music copyright in
particular is a is very very weird
because to copyright a song you have to
write it on sheet music if you haven't
written on sheet music you can't
copyright it as a songwriter and you're
going to see you know when you go and
see a lucasfilm movie they used to have
that thx noise like that huge
and the whole cinema would check you
guys this is really cool um and they
went to copyright then the library of
congress said they couldn't copyright it
because it didn't have a score and so
ben bert who's lucasfilm sounds like he
wrote the most messed up score you've
ever seen on one page of stave music and
then he sent it to the library of
congress and went uh this is the thx
deep wave noise please i'd like to be
registered as the writer of this piece
of work and they went oh no problem mr
burt thank you very much
um so uh yeah there are some really
really kind of interesting questions
around you know credit and copyright and
liability and and all this kind of stuff
but you know don't let the scary
questions uh detract from the fact that
there is awesome new art and music out
there which we not thought of yet
because we've never had the the
technology to explore these things
before um
and i'm sure it'll only be a matter of
time before some of it makes it into the
charts not that anyone listens to charts
anymore but you know any other questions
folks
uh yeah i see a raised hand
did you ever find out who would win
between optimus prime and darth vader
you see i have access to a lot more
material now like you know really when i
was a kid i think i had two transformers
comic books and i had what i remembered
from seeing return of the jedi at the
drive-in and everything else was my
friends and i going oh yeah well i i
reckon darth vader's got an electric
space horse and it was like oh wow he
knows a lot about that we had no idea um
i think it would have to be darth vader
because you know optimus prime is still
constrained by the the limits of
physical reality because there's no
magic and transformers they're just
really clever machines i mean you know
arthur c clark's definition of magic
whereas darth vader's got all that crazy
force stuff and so he could like force
push optimus prime off a cliff and game
over so
yeah evil will always win because good
is dumb
all right
thank you very much folks anybody who's
coming to the christmas dinner i'll see
you at the christmas dinner if not we're
back tomorrow for some more take it easy
have a good evening
you